knows every word to wet ass [ __ ]
yeah i have a problem with that but i
also gave up
i'm also like i give up i [ __ ] you can't
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do now
you know you took the internet took
everything away from me
including the sacred space between my
daughter she was [ __ ] singing
every word and i'm sitting there like
this like you know what i could do about
that
i could do about as much i was basically
a cow chewing grass
just i'll just be over here chewing my
cud because i can do nothing
as a father too [ __ ] she's like i'm
gonna back you i'm [ __ ]
done anime and then she's in the anime
these
are middle schoolers oh well not only
that anime is like well
um my favorite is todoroki he killed his
parents because uh so he's an anti-hero
and uh and he also cuts himself because
he's i'm like the [ __ ] is going on
it's the darkness anime is dark right
yeah
oh well there's different types of anime
so it's really up to what the
specific person likes it sounds like
your uh daughter's into like
a dark [ __ ] dude and so are her friends
okay and they sit around
until she runs with the weird posse they
listen to wet ass [ __ ] and watch
their wrists it is
in middle school that first of all they
know everything
because they have the internet okay
second of all
they are like she's like yeah and then
she's talking about
androgynous japanese assassin boys
and i don't have anything in common with
that and what happens is what's hard for
when you got little kids so you can
cuddle and talk and everything what's
gonna happen
is that you are gonna find yourself in a
situation with your children where you
have
zero in common boys might be a little
different your kids will be athletes
girls are but they're also into what i'm
into listen my daughter's
what's your wife she's a jock she loves
lacrosse she's obsessed with the cross
she watches
d1 women's lacrosse makes me watch it
she's got opinions she's always
practicing i get it
but there's i can't even relate to the
lacrosse you're not i can but i'm saying
there are just things that that the
internet brings into her life
and you will have [ __ ] all to do with it
watch this so she always says y'all and
what i realized is that instead of
saying she says y'all because you
guys is gender specific so she's being
gender sensitive oh interesting
yeah bro and you're like because she was
reading um uh fantasy novels and they
have a a large queer
um presence in fantasy novels so she's
like reading this stuff
and she's like well these girls are
kissing so she then what does she do she
goes to youtube
and goes down that rabbit hole and now
she's a trans activist
is she she's actually she's girls
i don't know man you're asking me
questions i don't want to answer right
now
i believe she's in the boys she's not
into anybody she doesn't seem like she's
gotten that stage yet dude
she's going to know oh road you know i'm
not saying a bad road
your being is going down a road you're
being antagonistic to me right now
sounds like your dog's going down
no no no no no we gotta we gotta edit
that out i know
that happens
no i'll get [ __ ] for it now listen up
here's the thing you [ __ ]
i don't know what's going on all i'm
saying is they grow up way too fast with
the internet day yeah and i have
nothing speeds things up yes because
you're not there when they're on tick
tock
and going down the different rabbit
holes that they're going down
but i just know that she will not read
jk rowling anymore because apparently jk
rowling is
uh transphobe and i'm like no she's not
and
i don't know what to say about it so
dicey how about
have you heard the lyrics to wet ass
[ __ ]
it's outrageous no
the whole thing is [ __ ] crazy when
and her and her friends they just know
i'm like you can't sing that in the car
you can't see that in my back seat when
i'm driving you can't do it and they
i gotta set the no they're just doing it
because it's bad
yeah like like with little nuts it's a
little nasty nwa and snoop dogg when we
were kids
my my nine-year-old is listening a
little not little nas
is is cause we have the streaming so he
hits it little now is that song
uh cocaine damn it i'll call me by your
name
yeah it's like the song isn't it
something like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah this one yeah coke with the video
where he's like
like he's giving satan a lot of laughter
i wanna [ __ ] you
and i want to do cocaine all that and
i'm like my nine-year-old is like i love
this song i'm like i i can't i can't do
this
i caught it bad yesterday hit me in a
place and you know wow hoping to catch a
romantic talking you're cute enough to
[ __ ] with me tonight
looking at the table oh i see his weed
and white baby you living the life but
you ain't living right cocaine and
drinking with your friends
you live in the dark boy i cannot
pretend i'm not fazed only here to sin
if eve ain't gonna it's actually
good [ __ ] lyrics by the way but are
you in now
are you in i'm 54. nine year old
i just don't want my nine year old to be
like play that song again
but is he in anybody else or
is he into anything else yeah he's in
other stuff bro he's in the hard rock
that's what he likes most of all yeah
are you in the hard drive no he likes
hard work
dude no he loves led zeppelin ac dc no
no he likes you
and that's fine no he likes hard rock
too he likes hip hop and hard rock
and he likes to and then i can't talk to
him when he's listening to music
he's in the back seat and i'm like how
was your day goes don't talk to me right
now
i'm grooving the music so he would
rather
we're very similar here and i said the
problem i talk to myself right i'm i'm
i'm never there right and i'm i'm never
we're driving
never present yeah and then we're
driving and
and i and i realize that i'm [ __ ]
having my own conversation is he present
in school though
sort of like i was the answer is no yeah
and then i look in the back seat and the
motherfucker's talking to himself just
like me
and i was like wow and then i call it in
your own world
he goes yup literally my favorite thing
to do
i'm like all right well my kid's gonna
be just like me and i hope he can
navigate the world
so let's see what happens it's out of
state by the way how about this
stand-up comedy that [ __ ] is
it's so weird to see
your little your clone all he does is
make his friends laugh
every one of them they're like he's
hilarious they all want to be around him
because he's
he that's he lives to make people laugh
and he's got a pretty sophisticated
sense of humor
he does characters so it's it's weird
when uh
other parents just let [ __ ] slide like
my kid does jutsu and there's one kid
who just he doesn't listen and dad's
like yeah i was just like i'm like
yeah that's fine dude but [ __ ] get
the kid in line dude yes
like or why bring him yes like if he's
not gonna do what the other kid's doing
why bring him in i believe in discipline
like that
i have to i mean or don't come but a lot
of people but a lot of parents
don't there's a school of thought that
kind of says it's like two ways of
thinking right they're two schools of
thought one is
like and it's actually kind of a
conservative liberal kind of mindset
so like like if you ever think about
conservatives they're like we need law
and order
you gotta have law order and you gotta
have rules church and all that stuff
because what happens is if you let
people just do their thing
they'll be [ __ ] in the streets and
shooting everybody and liberals tend the
other
that that mentality is like wait a
minute that's all restrictions you put
your religious direction let me know
let me breathe and be loose yeah well
yeah but some people are
either one side or the other and it just
depends on if you think people i think
it just depends on the person
some people don't need chains other
people need some [ __ ]
they need something yeah
yeah the [ __ ] that's good for you like i
have this joke where it's like when
you're young if it feels good
you're like this is the truth let's move
in together who needs money we have each
other when you're older and something
feels good you're like the [ __ ] is the
catch what's going on who's paying for
this you know
and that's really true you don't trust
things that are that feel good because
there's got to be a price to pay